oui c'est un coup de coeur littéraires
il fallait pas coutume assez bien pour
un livre qui sort là qui vient de sortir
la restants il s'appelle ne signalait
pas vu voilà et c'est un livre signé
émirates offs qui bat une écrivaine que
j'adore et effet un livre s'est inquiété
dans le panneau publicitaire la balle
oui mais là elle sort un livre donc je
pense qu'il s'agit de photos
voilà c'est un peu ça va cogner dans
l'ensemble ont préféré j'adore à des
journaux de mettet en d'autres oui bah
oui bah déjà vu celle-ci oui ou non le
droit libre à la liste un saint maclou
évidemment c'est du budget c'est du
buffle pas s'il ya aussi des mollahs ont
bien des choses comme ça je ne veux pas
que tu vois ça va tu vois ça non mais
c'est sa silhouette est ce qu'on doit
dès maintenant moi je vais vous dire je
m'en balance mais c'est pas du tout le
monde a lancé vous de dire si c'est pas
fou c'est votre tout de suite je me suis
renseigné sur ce bouquin et 990
exemplaire et ça coûte 90 bal el hout et
il est devenu l'auteur 90 da seulement
avec tak badaboum département qui bat
les paccots pour moi aussi je peux
l'acheter avec plaisir j'adore je dois
peut-être que moi elle m'a fait tant
couler ce que j'allais aller ces points
n'est pas plus câlin c'est son style
alain alors là il coûtait l'ordre à 6 à
peu le distraire et me rendent libres
pour autant je lâche andré cette news
exemplaires merci matt est simple c'est
les livres qu'on feuillette il ya les
livres qu'on effeuille manifestement
suicide la seconde catégorie
jean-marc un truc c'est que george ne
veut plus regarder isabelle plus de
talent elle est comme ça il sait dire
oui ou non il ya une persona je ne vais
pas lâcher le regard du soin qu'il n'a
pas de tatouage c'est bien ouais mais
depuis tout à l'heure voulue pc
parce qu'avec les idoles tatouage reboot
ces modes team
moi j'aime bien les hommes virils donc
forcé sacré regardez moi était jaloux
bizarre genre ça peut être votre 6,10 à
rennes parce que pardon et l merci ça
peut être votre style isabelle elle s'en
foutent vous répondre un but est la mal
aimée une très belle femme
et voilà non mais c'est vrai très très
belle femme les séries vous aimez ce
livre contient rocha gala la féministe
du groupe mais moi je répète ce que j'ai
toujours dit je pense que chaque femme
de faire ce qu'elle veut de son corps
donc si ça lui fait plaisir de publier
les photos qu'elle a pris en pole avec
ça fait plaisir
visiblement à d'autres personnes grand
bien lui fasse
eh bien merci ben voilà